I don't know if you've seen the sort of
ridiculous a animation to be used
animated drawings like the ginger,
the genderbread person or the gender
Unicorn.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I have.
Yeah,
and so those are being pushed forward
very hard in institutions all across
Canada,
elementary schools,
junior high schools,
the military,
the police,
you name it,
where there's this tremendous emphasis
on the social construction of identity
and it's as if the social
constructionists have taken to the law
to enforce what they cannot prove
scientifically what they failed to prove
scientifically or what's even being
disproved scientifically,
which would be more accurate way of
thinking about it.
Then the fact that there was an all out
assault on,
on biology by the left is unbelievably.
I'm ominous in my estimation.
Yeah,
I agree.
Just two things on that.
We've got an article coming out on
written by two evolutionary
psychologists on the false dichotomy
between sex and gender and they give it
some historical context.
So the fault.
That false dichotomy I think started
with Moonee.
Yes,
exactly.
And it's.
And then it was weaponized by feminists
to deny biology entered denied sex
differences.
Basically.
So that's it.
Very strange thing for feminists to do.
One of the things that James Demore has
just pointed out lately,
he's the guy that wrote that memo for
Google,
is that
the problem with denying the sex
differences is that you automatically
make the argument that if there are sex
differences,
essentially they're making the argument
that the female differences or something
like inferior because why would you
object to their existence otherwise?
And memo was actually quite careful
because he said,
well we should take a look at these
differences and if we want to maximize
the economic utility of women,
which seems to be a reasonable thing to
do,
then we should actually have a serious
discussion about what the differences
are and see if we could set up our
institution so that we can take
advantage of the,
of the difference in perspective and
orientation.
But the two sexes might bring to bear on
the,
on the workplace and on economic issues
in general.
And you don't use that happening because
people are starting to sort themselves
out into occupations bisects
essentially.
And you know,
the longterm social consequences of that
aren't obvious.
And we don't know how to balance that,
but it's,
it doesn't,
it isn't necessarily the case that it's
a bad thing.
No.
Yeah.
And my position has always been that
women have probably more to lose when
sex differences are denied.
I think because of women's biological
clock and the,
the fact that we bear much more of a
burden when it comes to child bearing
and child weary.
If you denied that
women pay a huge price,
if,
if you denied the fact that what women
go through that to bear children.
Firstly,
I think we need to separate mothers out
from women.
There's this sort of a conflation when
we talk about things like the gender gap
where there's a lot of the rhetoric
implies that all women are discriminated
against the women who pay a penalty,
our mothers and we,
we need to talk about that more and we,
we shouldn't minimize the,
the work and the sacrifice and,
and all of the,
the,
the costs and the energy that we've been
pouring into that.
And I think when we do ny sex
differences,
we sort of,
um,
we,
we do,
we minimize and we,
um,
sort of dismiss everything that women do
that is female normally receive,
such as caring and,
and,
and working for others and sacrificing
pay for their children.
And you know,
all of these things.
Right.
Well,
no,
I agree with you.
Maybe a month ago we were talking to her
last night.
She's trying to finish up her degree.
She's also had some health problems that
have interfered with that.
You know,
she was talking to us last night about
that.
She looked tired.
She had bags under her eyes.
I mean she's very happy to have the baby
and it's going very well and all of
that.
But the first year after you have a
baby,
you're basically done.
You don't get it.
You don't get any sleep.
You're absolutely overwhelmed,
especially for the first six months with
a new instance,
especially if you're a first time mother
because like,
what the hell do you know about taking
care of this incredibly complicated
thing.
And it produces all sorts of biochemical
changes and it's really hard on your
body and there's a long recovery period
and you're much more dependent on your
familial structure than you were before.
And the,
I like,
I mean,
it's crazy that we even have to have
this conversation,
but I like your distinction between
women and mothers and you know,
there's one of the problems that I've
had with,
with classic feminism,
if you could use that term,
is that there's absolutely no respect
built into it for the maternal role.
And I really think that that's,
that's appalling on a variety of levels,
including appalling for men because like
one of the things I've experienced is
that I've had a pretty intense career.
I would say.
I've been very fortunate in that manner.
I've had a lot of familial support and
support from my wife for that.
And you know,
we kind of parsed our life up in a
relatively traditional manner because
she was quite interested in having
children by the time we got together.
And um,
I was perfectly willing to go along with
artists if I could also continue what
are my career pursuits,
which were also necessary for our
financial stability.
But for me,
like the domestic realm has been an
incredibly meaningful part of my life.
Like I,
I,
I'm really happy in my marriage and
blast I would say in my marriage.
And I loved having kids and,
and for me,
my home has always been a refuge from,
from the insanity of the world in some
sense.
And I think our society is,
it's so crazily skewed towards public
performance,
let's say that we've denied the utility
of the domestic sphere and that really
is terrible for women because especially
with regards to kids because that is
their,
that is the role that they dominate,
let's say,
or,
or Dominique did they contribute most
mightily to,
let's put it that way.
And it,
it's almost as if our society
regardless,
that is kind of an emphasis on,
you know.
And I think it's crazy.
I think it makes people miserable.
And I understand why the early feminists
sort of downplayed the domestic sphere
because they,
they were trapped in the domestic sphere
and they wanted opportunities and I'm a,
I'm one of those women who would have
been an early feminist probably because
I crave intellectual stimulation and I
would have been,
if I'd never had an opportunity to have
a career,
I would have been bored and that kind of
thing.
But now in 2017 I can go and get a job
as a psychologist that can run a website
and,
you know,
I can do everything that a man can,
but I'm still biologically a female.
And so when it comes to having kids,
a cost is on me and the women in my
life,
for example,
um,
my,
my own mother who super maternal and
comes and helps with the children.
I see how we don't keep that status and
prestige anymore.
And it's,
it's just this a male normative sphere
where
you can monetize something or something,
like you said,
public performance.
We can,
we afford that status and prestige.
But this invisible caring work that
women are so good at.
And some women are exceptional that it's
supported,
no prestige whatsoever.
There's often not
you know,
or notice for little kids,
for example,
even though our little kids were very
well behaved,
that she was treated,
she wasn't treated well in the public
sphere,
she wasn't treated well in restaurants.
I think people were afraid.
I think that was part of it in some
sense.
You know,
they were afraid that if she showed up
in a public place with children that
there would be disruption of one form or
another.
So,
but it was certainly the case that I
would say she received the opposite of
respect and look deeply into architect
will symbolism and the function that it
plays in.
Of course,
one of the divine images that sits at
the bottom of western culture and
Western culture is the image of the
divine mother and the mother of the
savior of humanity,
which is an archetypal idea because
every baby has the possibility of
growing up to be a redemptive figure.
Now that's,
that's the reason that that's an
archetypal figures because any society
that doesn't worship but so to speak
doesn't give it a very high value,
will nourish.
Now the fact if the declining,
the catastrophic declining birth rate in
the West is a real example of our
willful blindness towards that sacred
image and it's a big problem and it is
the case that I think if,
if the,
if the feminists we're actually working
on behalf of femininity,
which is essentially what they claim,
that they would be working a hell of a
lot harder to elevate the status of
mothers.
You know?
Yeah.
Other than women,
I think that's a really good distinction
that you're drawing.
Even though it seems rather self
evident,
it's,
it's not,
and you're not the same.
Once you become a mother,
you're a different sort of person.
And I also think women who don't have
children or rather intimidated and
afraid of that,
and that's perfectly understandable
because it isn't radical transformation.
But I would also say,
and I've thought this for years,
that you don't actually become mature.
You don't actually become an adult until
you have children.
And I know that that's a statement that
irritates the hell out of people,
but it's something that I stand by it.
You're not an adult until someone else
matters more than you do.
And
to make real sacrifices.
Yes,
exactly.
Well,
and especially as a mother,
you sacrifice yourself as the person of
prime importance and,
and,
and you know,
you,
you do it,
I suppose happily in some sense because
generally you fall in love with your
baby relatively rapidly and thank God
for that because their lots of trouble.
Um,
you know,
I was recounting the story of my
daughter and she is trying to.
She was planning to take a course in
biology online this,
this semester in order to move towards
the completion of her degree.
And we told her last,
she said she was overwhelmed when we
went and talked to her last night and we
told her just to leave it be because
first year is so intense that you're,
you're completely overwhelmed by it.
And it's necessary because you want to
get your baby off to a good start and
get that relationship functioning
properly.